[Music]
we have been designing and producing supercomputer servers,
cyber security products and
mission-critical systems for the world
of defense for a few years now our
products have integrated dia technologies
to optimize our supercomputers,
their efficiency and their
electrical consumption or  are coupled with
artificial intelligence software
to connect our edge servers
vision and motion detection software
from the launch of
developments we encountered
issues of trust and
robustness of the models how to
guarantee our customers their
operation throughout  the lifespan of products
despite their evolution and that of their
environment they must remain
relevant it is to address this
problem in collaborative mode with
industrial and academic partners
that we are joining the
yves confidence project we are
particularly motivated by the idea  d  e
produce tools of
sovereign confidence it is a requirement of our
customers it is therefore necessary that the
multi as well as the models
guarantee robustness and reliability
the cases of use tutti will relate to
predictive maintenance digital vision
and the improvement of
numerical simulation calculations thanks
to artificial intelligence the first
work towards uni ha precise long-
term and real time opens up two
magnificent perspectives
[Music]